[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja gerade in
diesen Tagen zeigt sich wie wichtig die
Europäische Union ist dass wir die EU
dringlicher denn je brauchen und sie
vermehrt sie haben ja gerade große Worte
darüber gefunden dass wir an einem
Europa der Zukunft bauen müssen aber
wenn man zurückschaut auf die Politik
der CDU und CSU in den letzten Jahren in
Europa dann war es gerade der Kurs von
Wolfgang Schäuble der Europa so
gespalten hat der besserwisserische
belehrende Ton den Wolfgang Schäuble dem
die Union gegenüber insbesondere die
Ländern Süd Europas hatten dieser elende
Kurs der Austeritätspolitik mit dem Sie
viele Süd europäische Länder zur
Privatisierung gezwungen haben die
richtige Investition verhindert haben
das ist ihr Erbe und das hat Deutschland
Ruf bei unseren europäischen
Nachbarländern schwer belastet das ist
ihr Erde in Europa Politik
ja wir arbeiten an einer Europa der
Zukunft und das ist wirklich harte
Arbeit 27 Mitgliedstaaten mit vielen
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven die jeden
Tag miteinander um den besten Weg
bringen aber auch zeigen dass wir
handeln können wir haben hart gerungen
um harte Sanktionen gegen den Iran ein
Regime das erfurchtbare Weise Terror
ausübt gegen seine eigene Bevölkerung
das junge Menschen einsperrt foltert und
hinrichtet nur weil sie es wagen eine
eigene Meinung zu haben nur weil sie es
wagen von einem Leben in Freiheit zu
träumen das auszuhalten das ist extrem
schwer und wir arbeiten jeden Tag daran
dafür zu sorgen dass die Welt hinschauen
wir arbeiten jeden Tag daran ist diesem
Regime schwerer zu machen und
insbesondere die deutsche
Außenministerin war ist doch die dafür
gesorgt hat dass am Montag weitere
Sanktionen in der Europäischen Union
beschlossen werden und ganz persönlich
herzlichen Dank Annalena dafür ich weiß
wie hart das ist was du da gerade
leistest
aber sie haben erst wenn sie das hier
zurecht ansprechen mit dem Iran dann
muss ich Ihnen sagen ich werde Ihnen
persönlich nicht vergessen dass sie hier
im Plenum gelacht haben als die deutsche
Außenministerin über feministische
Außenpolitik gesprochen hat sie haben
sich zurückgelehnt breitbeinig und haben
das Thema nichts ernst genommen als wir
das auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt haben
fangen sie erstmal mit ihrer eigenen
Wertehaltung an bevor sie hier andere
kritisieren wir haben in Europa um die
besten Antworten das heißt auch zum
Beispiel im Umgang mit Orban es war
schäbig das Organ ausgerechnet die
Hilfen für die Ukraine genutzt hat um
die Europäische Union zu erpressen gut
dass ich eine Mehrheit der
Mitgliedstaaten nicht davon hat
beeindrucken lassen ja es hätte noch
mehr sein müssen aber das der
rechtsstaatlichkeitsmechanismus ist
angewendet wird das ist ein historisches
Signal und zeigt wozu die Europäische
Union in diesen Zeiten fähig ist und
wozu europäische unionfähig ist das hat
sie insbesondere gezeigt angesichts des
furchtbaren angriffskriegs den Russland
gegen die Ukraine geführt hat wir haben
zusammengestanden wir haben schnelle und
harte sanktionspakete auf den Weg
gebracht und gerade jetzt in diesem
Winter der lang dunkel und kalt wird für
die Menschen in der Ukraine ist es so
wichtig dass wir weiterhin mehr helfen
beim Thema zivile Infrastruktur mit
Hilfsgütern mit Generationen mit
Heizgeräten mit Containern all das was
wir liefern können um den Menschen in
der Ukraine jetzt durch diese Zeit zu
helfen müssen wir tun und das heißt auch
Unterstützung mit Waffen heißt auch
Unterstützung mit mehr Waffen das ist
wichtig in dieser Zeit
aber Herr Merz wenn Sie hier diese Worte
über die Ukraine finden und die waren
angemessen und empathisch am Anfang dann
sage ich Ihnen auch Solidarität mit der
Ukraine zeigt sich auch im Umgang mit
geflüchteten mit den Menschen die hier
hinkommen die unsere Hilfe brauchen und
dass die Union in dieser Zeit in der so
viele Menschen auf unsere Unterstützung
angewiesen sind immer wieder Kampagnen
gegen geflüchtete fährt immer wieder
schärficks wie die CSU in dieser Woche
gegen geflüchtete Macht über
sozialtourismus spricht über politische
spricht das ist unsolidarisch auch
gegenüber den Menschen aus der Ukraine
das macht das Leben von diesen Menschen
hier schwieriger und das ist ihre
Verantwortung die sie auch haben
ja und wir brauchen die EU auch um
Antworten zu geben auf die großen
geopolitischen Herausforderungen dieser
Zeit im Umgang mit China und auch im
Umgang mit den USA das was die USA mit
dem Inflation reduction Act machen das
ist eine krasse Ansage auf der einen
Seite zeigen sie wie ernst man machen
kann beim Klimaschutz und auf der
anderen Seite ist es eine
Herausforderung für uns weil diese
Politik im Kern protektionistisch ist
darauf müssen wir in der Europäischen
Union eine Antwort geben unser Ziel ist
hierbei klar wir müssen Europa zum
Leitmarkt machen für
Zukunftstechnologien zum Leitmarkt
machen für grüne Technologien das zu
fördern ist die beste Antwort die wir
auf den Flächen redakt geben können
dazu gehört übrigens auch auch unserer
Industrie hier vor Ort zu helfen fit zu
werden für den klimaneutralen Markt der
Zukunft und Herr März dieser Reflex
immer alles zu kritisieren was die
Regierung macht und immer alles doof zu
finden nur weil es von der Regierung
kommt die hat genau an dieser Stelle
nicht funktioniert als sie Herr
harderberg dafür kritisiert haben dass
wir jetzt Verträge mit der Industrie
auflegen damit sie umstellen können auf
grünem Wasserstoff damit sie umstellen
können auf eine klimaneutrale
Stahlproduktion da haben sie das
kritisiert haben das schlecht gefunden
und haben sogar vergessen dass es in
ihrem eigenen Bundestagswahlprogramm
statt dieser Reflex einfach nur alles
durchzufinden der ist im Kern
populistisch der ist im Kern nicht
ernsthaft und ich wundere mich wirklich
ich habe in den letzten Wochen mehr
fertig von der Union gefunden zu
irgendwelchen Leuten die sich auf
Straßen festkleben als eine Zukunft
gerichtete Antwort für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland sie
hatten mal vor eine Wirtschaftspartei zu
sein im Kern haben sie keine Antworten
auf die Zukunft unseres Landes will aber
der klimaneutralen Wirtschaft noch beim
Thema fachkräftestrategie wo sie auch
einfach gegen alles sind was der
Wirtschaft helfen würde den
Fachkräftemangel in diesem Land zu
bekämpfen das ist keine ernsthafte
Oppositionspolitik die CDU hatte mal den
Anspruch eine staatstragende Partei zu
sein momentan haben sie sich in eine
Populismus Opposition
zurückgezogen ich hoffe sie kriegen das
in Zukunft wieder besser hin
[Applaus]